this is absolutely tremendous
Donald Trump is fully turning on
evangelicals for his 2024 run as the
race seems to be collapsing for Trump we
never count him out we know what
happened in 2016. but Trump is in
trouble here early trouble and
evangelicals seem to be abandoning him
and he is now furious with the
evangelicals this is part of that
interview we looked at earlier where he
appeared on the water cooler with David
Brody appearing by phone Trump's new
thing he's on by phone not by video and
uh here he is talking about the
disloyalty of Evangelical leaders who
have the audacity not to endorse Trump
you were The Ultimate Fighter uh the
ultimate counter puncher for sure and
that makes me think of evangelicals why
they loved you uh twice in those
elections and you announced when you
announce your candidacy at least as it
stands now some of these prominent
Evangelical leaders who backed you last
time they're not yet willing to commit
like Robert Jefferson's not some others
it's seems like many of them are waiting
to see how the field takes shape before
backing anyone what is your message to
them
well I don't really care
oh my goodness antifa has gotten into
Trump's audio
it's great disloyalty as the world of
politics and that decided disloyalty
because nobody as you know and you would
know better than anybody because you do
such a great job nobody has ever done
more for right to life than Donald Trump
I put three Supreme Court Justices who
all voted and they got something that
they've been fighting for for 64 years
or many many years right nobody thought
they could win it you know they they won
uh Roe v Wade they won they finally won
and you know I was a little disappointed
because uh I thought they could have
fought much harder during the election
during the 22 election because you know
they won and a lot of them uh
didn't fight or weren't really around
the site and it did energize
the Democrats so it's a sign of
disloyalty says Trump that these
Evangelical leaders won't come out and
support him now here's the reality it
never made sense for Evangelical
Republicans to support Donald Trump it
never made sense and so now use whatever
phrase you like the chickens are coming
home to roost what goes around comes
around the bill is come do whatever this
was a sort of Faustian pact all along
for the evangelicals they really didn't
like Hillary they sort of wanted Ted
Cruz and then that didn't work out and
Trump called Ted Cruz's wife ugly and
things didn't go well and ultimately
they had Trump or Hillary as their
choice
um and then it was Trump or Biden and
Biden's Catholic and a lot of
evangelicals don't like that either and
so they went with Trump overwhelmingly
but it never made sense look at Trump's
past Behavior look at Trump's past
statements the extramarital affairs uh
the profanity the um you know way that
he has talked about women in the past it
doesn't align with what the evangelicals
want us to believe other Christian
values now want us to believe is doing
some heavy lifting there because are
these really their values that's kind of
a different question Trump's policy by
the way Trump's policies on health care
and immigration aren't really very
Christian either based on what are more
uh
more enlightened understandings of what
those Christian views are
um and at the end of the day the
evangelicals now are saying to
themselves we might not have to go with
Trump let's not jump on the Trump train
early because maybe somebody else will
actually best Trump in the Republican
primary so the evangelicals seemingly
turning on Trump trump immediately
turning on the evangelicals because
remember anyone who doesn't immediately
wholeheartedly and unanimously support
Trump
is being disloyal a couple weeks ago it
was the Jews being disloyal to Trump now
it's the evangelicals that's the framing
that's the that's the black white
thinking that people like Trump
narcissists egomaniacs that is the
framing through which they interpret
others actions we're going to take a
very quick break make sure you're
subscribed to the YouTube channel at
youtube.com the davidpackman show what a
program we have for you today
one of our sponsors is curiositystream
the best place to find and watch
documentaries on politics history
science technology nature you name it
they have it curiosity stream has a
deeper collection of documentaries than
any other streaming service they add new
titles every week including exclusive
award-winning films and shows you can't
watch anywhere else I just watched
ancient engineering
fascinating insights into how stuff was
built before modern technology and the
Industrial Revolution you can watch
curiositystream on all of your devices
phone desktop game console Smart TV I'm
always finding great documentaries on
curiosity stream that I can't find on
any other platforms it's really the only
place to go four documentaries and they
have a great deal for my audience you
can get curiosity stream for an entire
year for 15 bucks that's a dollar 25 a
month go to curiositystream.com
Pacman and use the code Pacman the link
is down below